his writings that this power was
intended to be deluded it was to be
balanced amongst the chambers that the
judicial branch was viewed as the
weakest of the three branches of
government not because it wasn't equal
in power but because it didn't
have some of the mechanisms that the
other two branches do to protect it
and while the president makes that
appointment makes that appointment it is
this chamber
the sole duty of this chamber in the
constitution
to agree or disagree with that
nomination
we saw that disagreement occur in 2016
where this chamber did not give its
consent
to a nomination later neil gorsuch
colorado neil gorsuch was confirmed to
the supreme court
and just a matter of a little more than
a month ago
we lost a trail blazing leader in
justice ruth bader ginsburg
leaving open another seat on the supreme
court that we are now
asked to fill federal 78
also written by alexander hamilton has
been referenced many times on the floor
and
this past year and particularly during
this debate
wrote about the the constitution being
fundamental law that
it's the will of the people and that the
courts are the only true
guardians the only true guardians of the
constitution that the constitution is
the highest man-made law
that any legislative act to the contrary
uh must be held
void by the court since and i quote the
interpretation of the laws is the proper
and peculiar province
of the course that it was the
guardian of the constitution when
madison was talking about
this in the first congress he introduced
of course the amendments that became
what we call
the bill of rights today he said that
the courts would quote consider
themselves in a peculiar manner
the guardians of those rights they would
be an impenetrable
bulwark against every assumption of
power in the legislative or the
executive
they will be naturally led to resist
every encroachment upon rights expressly
stipulated for in the constitution
by the declaration of rights
and that idea of this guardians of the
constitution that the court plays
is a hallmark of our democracy today
and whether or not a justice has the
support
of a member of this chamber i don't
believe that anyone would deny
that role that our courts must play
and that is that role as guardian
of the constitution but it is clear
in the confirmation hearing for
judge barrett that some people believe
the guardian of the constitution takes
on a different hue that there is
more to that role than simply looking at
the law
and making a decision based on the law
as some called it i believe it was
justice scalia and
perhaps paraphrased by justice gorsuch
that a judge's role is to call balls and
strikes i would add to that it is not
their role to call the pitch
but what we saw during the judiciary
committee hearings of course was
a viewpoint of of some that a judge
should be more
than calling balls and strikes a
judge should be in effect a super
legislator that a judge should
accomplish things that this chamber this
congress
has failed to do that if there is a
shortcoming in a policy
that a judge or justice would look the
other way and
and fill in that policy or write that
policy or proactively create
that policy that again going back to
what we have known throughout this
country as the guardians of the
constitution
guardians of the constitution don't make
up policy
they don't fill voids of new policies
that the legislators didn't do or
couldn't do because they couldn't get it
through their chamber
so they decided they would count on a
judge to do it somewhere else
that's not the role of the courts it's
certainly not the role
of a guardian of the constitution
a guardian of the constitution is
somebody who looks at the law and makes
decisions the law
upholds and protects that will of the
people the fundamental law
of the people and of course
an activist judge activist justice
would be reaching into the law
to fit their own personal opinion or
beliefs
to craft something that they believe is
perhaps more in line with what they
thought somebody wanted more in line
with their own opinions
instead of looking at that letter of
the law and i think it's important that
we
keep in mind that's not the role of the
courts
if this chamber can't pass a policy or a
law if it can't
have its own victory in carrying the day
in an argument it's not up to a judge or
a justice
to fill in the blank they have to
rule and carry out the law
and so that's a real key distinction
that we saw during the
judicial committee the judiciary
committee debates
that role of policy maker that some wish
judge barrett to be versus that role of
protector that guardian
of the constitution calling balls and
strikes
i look at any nominee for the courts
whether it's a district court or
appellate court or a
supreme court through a lens of are they
going to protect that constitution
are they going to uphold the
constitution are they going to fight to
defend it that guardian of the
constitution
are they going to protect and do the
same with the law outside of
the constitution the laws the statutes
that this body enacts and passes
signed into law by the president will
that judge or justice
uphold and defend that law not make that
law not change that law
but uphold the law
and of course that guardian of the
constitution role
that they will play there's no doubt
that
judge barrett's qualifications are
immense
uh her qualifications as a member of our
great american community somebody with a
beautiful family it's mind-boggling
jamie and i uh have a challenge with our
three kids
making sure they get to school on time
making sure they're getting their
homework done i can't imagine
seven children while also carrying the
schedule
that their family family does but it's a
testament to the incredible power and
leadership
of their family their dedication to
being upstanding citizens of this nation
and giving back to this nation this new
pursuit
we know the the keen intellect that has
been shared with this country over the
last several years
in the seventh circuit court of appeals
we know her time as a law professor and
have had
the opportunity to look over a decade
plus
worth of work and we know that she
is a person of faith
in our communities and has come under
incredible attacks because of that faith
and
we know in this chamber that our
constitution actually
forbids the kinds of attacks that we
have seen
on her faith
our constitution makes it clear there is
no religious test
our constitution actually makes it very
clear that you cannot vote
or deny public service appointments to
someone
because of their religious beliefs we've
seen it done we've seen it tried
especially over the last congress
we saw it done at the budget committee
with the nomination
of russ vogt to be the deputy director
of the office of management and budget
when a colleague of ours basically said
because of his
deeply held christian beliefs
that he was not qualified to be
a public servant in this country
and i i hope the american people are
hearing what is happening in some of
these
debates that amy coney bear is attacked
because of her faith
but it's not just limited or isolated to
her there are others
who are more and more accustomed
or who feel more more empowered
emboldened
to use a person's faith
to deny them their vote
to a position in our government
that is an unconstitutional test
that some in this chamber are starting
to rely on and i hope the american
people will
use this opportunity to see through to
reject it
to get back to the values of our
constitution and the intent
of that language
i had a conversation with judge barrett
the chance to to visit with her and
i talked about those three
qualifications to up
hold the constitution will you fight to
protect the constitution
will you protect the law and will you
avoid
being that activist legislator will you
avoid legislating from the bench
and received her commitment but that is
exactly the kind of judge
that she will be somebody to be that
guardian of the constitution the
protector of the law to call
balls and strikes i talked to her about
the importance that
i know that the vote that i cast for her
is something that matters not just next
year the next year but 10 and 20 years
from now as she is on that court
that that same view will remain and she
assured me that it will
because of the the same reason that i
wanted to
that's the future of our kids and their
kids
and she knows it means everything to her
children as well
to protect our nation's laws and
constitution and to avoid
that attempt that desire that pull at
the heart
to legislate even if you even if you
want to come
out with an opinion that is different
than your own
interpretation of the law you have to
follow the law
and that's what she has assured me she
has done she's assured me that there are
moments and rulings that she has issued
that she would have preferred a
different outcome personally
but that's not what the law required and
that's why she ruled the way
that she did
in talking to my colleagues on the
judiciary committee they talked about
her understanding of the law and
watching the hearings you could
sense the deep commitment and devotion
to
the law there was a time
several decades ago when president
ronald reagan went to
introduce justice sandra day o'connor
to a group of federal
judges at the white house
and ronald reagan in his speech talked
about what it means to be a judge he
talked about the
exacting standards of integrity fairness
and
intellect that's required for a federal
judgeship that it provides reassurance
to all of us that our ideals of liberty
and justice
are alive and well he went on to talk
about the most important quality that we
could have in a judge and that was
wisdom
that wisdom is the quality that we look
for most and i think you can sense the
great deal
of wisdom in amy coney barrett
he went on to say that we demand of our
judges a wisdom that knows no
time has no prejudice
and once no other reward
we entrust judges with our ideals and
freedom and our future depends on the
way
that judge defines it
it requires the lonely courage
of a patriot and he went on to say that
a judge is a guardian of freedom for
generations yet
unborn and so i hope that my colleagues
will support
the nomination of amy coney barrett
if you could take the politics out of
the place
she would probably have a unanimous vote
unfortunately the politicization
of this nomination
is going to prevent that but i just urge
my colleagues to look past the politics
to look past the partisanship
and to vote for a truly qualified
justice who is committed
to the law to the constitution who has
committed against
activism on the bench and who will make
sure that
our country for generations to come has
a protector that guardian of the
constitution with the wisdom
to get the job done i urge my colleagues
to support justice amy coney barrett and
i am
honored in just a few hours to know that
i will be able to cast a vote in support
of justice
soon to be justice amy coney barrett mr
president i yield the floor
senator from north carolina thank you mr
president
um mr president i ask unanimous consent
that my full statement be added to the
record without objection
thank you mr president my uh my staff i
want to thank my staff elliot who's here
on the floor
brad cirillo seth and brad for all the
work
that they've done as we've gone through
the nomination process and
i was reviewing my prepared remarks this
morning and then i was
reflected back on a very important
moment during the judiciary committee
hearing
where senator cornyn asked he said if
you can see among all of us we have
three ring binders we have staff behind
us we've taken weeks to prepare and
you're about
to go through some 20 hours of questions
would you mind sharing with us
your notes she looked at a blank notepad
that was given to her by the
by the chairman it had nothing on it she
came to that committee
fully prepared to answer any question
from the 22 members of the judiciary
committee
purely from what's up there and she did
an extraordinary job
the reason she did an extraordinary job
is because she's had an extraordinary
career both as a student beginning as a
student
then going to rhodes college where she
was magna [ __ ] laude
then going to notre dame school of law
where she graduated first in her class
she went on to be a professor at notre
dame and she was
multiple times voted the distinguished
professor
by a broad spectrum of liberal
and conservative students she's also
proven as a judge
with some 600 cases going through the
7th circuit that she has an encyclopedic
knowledge
of that law there were so many times
when members on the other side of the
aisle would try and trip her up or ask
her a question
she had no notes to refer to she got the
specifics of the case right and what she
demonstrated throughout the entire
hearing process which i attended
was that she interprets she does her job
by doing two things
looking at the plain letter of the
constitution
understanding the limits of that that
the laws can have within the bounds of
the constitution and rule accordingly
now my colleagues on the other side of
the island judiciary committee
were constantly it was clear to me after
weeks of attacking
amy coney barrett not directly
but through surrogates that they were
trying to demonize this person before
they ever came before the committee like
they did
with justice kavanaugh but each and
every time they ask her a question
she brought them back to the boundaries
of the constitution
and the question of law before
in her case the circuit court and there
was just no way to trip her up so then
what happened
then they started talking about how
you're going to go to the supreme court
and you're going to overturn the
affordable care act they asked her
questions so they knew she couldn't
answer and justice ginsburg
pursuant the ginsburg rule they had no
intention no responsible judge would go
before the judiciary committee
and tell you how they're going to rule
on a future case
it's actually a violation of their code
of conduct
so she told them in so many instances
and what was interesting with some of
the members on the other side of the
aisle
was on the one hand they would say you
cannot overturn this president or that
president and in the same breath
they would say but we want to make sure
you overturn this president or that
president
in every and every time amy coney
barrett
was calm and composed and demonstrated
to everybody in that committee
that she's going to be objective she is
going to be
fair and she is going to stay within the
lines of the constitution
and the the matter of law that's before
now i think that it's very important to
have a judge like that
on the supreme court our religious
freedoms are at stake
our second amendment rights are at stake
we do have people that want
activist judges i don't want an activist
judge period not for a conservative
cause or a liberal cause
i want to judge that i know if i someday
go before the supreme court or any any
american
i want to know that i have a judge there
who's going to be fair who's going to be
thoughtful who's going to be impartial
and will always have a concern
for both sides of the argument but at
the end of the day know that they have a
responsibility
to judge objectively
now mr chairman or i'm sorry mr
president
i uh i've had a couple of opportunities
to meet with uh
amy coney barrett and and the last
meeting that i had with her in the
capitol just a few steps away from where
we are right now i brought two pocket
constitutions with me
and i said i have two granddaughters one
will be three next week the other one's
a little over two months old
and so would you mind signing these
constitutions
for sire and willow my granddaughters
and she said certainly she opened it up
and she signed their name and just said
dream big when they get a little bit
older
not old enough yet i'm going to get them
to understand
excuse me the significance
of that that quick note from an
incredible jurist
somebody who dreamed big and realized
her american dream
a mother of seven school-aged children
two adopted from haiti one with special
needs
she's going to be the first supreme
court justice female
on the supreme court with school-aged
children she has seven
of them she's able to manage the
stresses
and the challenges of being a working
mom while she's served with distinction
on the seventh circuit
while her husband works as well she's
realized her american dream
i believe that she's going to make sure
that everybody else
has the freedoms to do the same thing i
think
judge amy coney barrett is going to go
down in history
as one of the great justices on the u.s
supreme court
it is a shame as you just said in your
comments
a moment ago that this is even a divided
decision
and the non in a in a less political
time than we find ourselves today
i suspect that she'd have the unanimous
support of this body
much the same way that justice ginsburg
did
when she came before the senate but
today
i'm looking forward to voting for judge
amy coney barrett i'm looking forward to
watching her build on what's already a
very strong legacy
i'm looking forward to making sure that
we continue to have a court that's
independent
impartial focuses on protecting all of
our constitutional rights and freedoms
and i know without a doubt amy coney
barrett
is going to be one of those stewards in
the u.s supreme court
thank you mr president
mr president senator from maryland mr
president i rise in opposition to the
pending confirmation vote of amy coney
barrack
to be an associate justice of the
supreme court
the to fill the vacancy created by the
death of justice ruth bader ginsburg
will be lost in september of this year
justice ginsburg
was a champion of women's rights and
civil rights
and she is going to be sorely missed on
that court
article 2 section 2 of the constitution
provides that the president shall
nominate and by and with the advice and
consent of the senate shall appoint
judges of the supreme court
one of the senator's most solemn
responsibilities is to evaluate the
nominees qualifications
as well as the process the senate uses
to provide their advice and consent
for a lifetime appointment to our
highest court
i believe on both substance and process
this nomination should be rejected
first on process let's talk
about fairness let's talk about the
integrity of the senate
let's talk about living up to your own
words
let's talk about using the same rules
for republicans that you used for
democrats
let me remind my colleagues what
happened in 2016
in the senate during president obama's
final year
of a term in office in a presidential
election year
justice scalia died in february of 2016.
within just a few hours after the death
of justice scalia leader mcconnell
unilaterally announced
that the senate would not consider a
replacement for justice scalia
until after november 2016 presidential
elections
which established a year-long vacant
supreme court seat
the republican leader's action backed by
his caucus
set a very clear precedent under no
circumstances do senate republicans
consider a supreme court nominee
in a presidential election year it did
not matter that in march 2016
president obama appointed merrick
garland a respected d.c
circuit judge with bipartisan support
they would not meet with judge garland
hold a hearing or allow a vote on him
for 293
days in 2016 the presidential election
was
nearly nine months away four years ago
our republicans colleagues said nine
months was not
time enough leave it up to the voters
we will have we will do this whether
it's a democrat
or republican in the white house the
republican leader mitch mcconnell said
and i quote
mr president the next justice could
fundamentally alter
the direction of the supreme court and
have a profound impact on our country so
of course of course
the american people should have a say in
the court's direction
the american people may well elect a
president who decides to nominate judge
garland for senate consideration
the next president may also nominate
somebody very different
either way our view is this give the
people a voice
in the filling of this vacancy the
american people are perfectly capable
having their say on this issue so let
give them a voice let's let the american
people decide
the american people should have a voice
in selection of the next supreme court
justice therefore this vacancy
should not be filled until we have
a new president that was the republican
leader
several judiciary committee members made
similar statements after the death of
justice scalia
senators grassley graham cornyn lee and
cruz signed a letter to leader mcconnell
which read in part
we are in the midst of a great national
debate over the course of our country
will take in the coming years the
presidential election is well underway
and
americans have already began to cast
their votes as we mourn the tragic loss
of justice scalia
and celebrate his life's work the
american people are presented with an
exceedingly rare opportunity to decide
in a very real and concrete way
the direction the court will take over
the next generation the letter from my
republican colleagues concluded
we believe the people should have this
opportunity because our decision is
based on constitutional principle
and born on the necessity to protect the
will of the american people
this committee will not hold hearings on
any supreme court nominee after our
until we after our next president sworn
in on january 20th
2017. current judiciary committee
chairman graham explicitly addressed
this point in 2016.
in march 2016 senator graham then a
member of the judiciary committee said
i want you to use my words against me if
there's a republican president in 2016
and a vacancy occurs
in the last year of that first term you
can say
lindsey graham said let the next
president whoever it might be make that
nomination
and you can use my words against me and
you would be absolutely
right we are setting precedent here
today republicans are that in the last
year
of a presidential term that you're not
going to fill a vacancy on the supreme
court based
on what we're doing here today that's
going to be in the new rule
and i've repeatedly stated the election
cycle is well underway and the president
of the senate is not to confirm a
nominee
at this stage in the process and by the
way senator graham
reaffirmed that in 2018.
in the case of justice ginsburg's death
and vacancy in 2020
we are about 40 days away from a general
election not nine months
and mail and voting in record numbers
have already begun in several states
and of course early voting has started
in many states also
we are proceeding to a final vote on
this nominee for a lifetime appointment
just
days before election day and of
americans
and millions of americans have already
cast their their ballots
once again within an hours of justice
ginsburg's death
leader mcconnell unilaterally decreed
that the senate
will fill the vacancy before the
election peter mcconnell said that
president trump's nominee
will receive a vote on the floor of the
senate so i implore my republican
colleagues to stop this blatant
hypocrisy now
let's follow the mcconnell rule and let
the american people pick the next
president
and senate so they can weigh in on this
decision
just as senator mcconnell argued in 2016
when president obama nominated mayor
garland for
justice scalia c that the senate honored
justice ginsburg's legacy by continuing
to fight for the rights
she fought for her entire career both as
a litigator
circuit judge and finally as a supreme
court justice let us honor justice
ginsburg's dying wish
my most fervent wish is that i will not
be replaced
until a new president is installed
president trump's agenda is quite clear
when it comes to a strategy for the
supreme court
president trump has repeatedly said he
would appoint justices
in the mold of justice scalia as
president trump said on the campaign
trail
when asked what kind of justice he would
nominate
we're going to have a very strong test
we want a strong conservative people
that are extremely smart
scalia's a terrific judge clarence
thomas you look at him
he's been a stalwart he's been terrific
and we have others
president trump also talked about the
type of justices he did not like
when he went on the campaign trail he
said i'm disappointed in roberts because
he gave us obamacare
he had two chances to end obamacare he
should have ended it
by every single measurement and he
didn't do it
so that was a disappointing one
everybody thought he was good
he was a bush appointee he was somebody
that should have frankly
ended obamacare and he didn't
when president trump announced judge amy
coney barrett's nomination to the
supreme court
baird herself highlighted the
ideological parallels between her
and her mentor justice scalia she said
about justice
scalia his judicial philosophy
is mine too judge barrett was a supreme
court clerk for justice scalia
justice scalia was one of the most
staunchly conservative members
of the supreme court justice scalia
voted to strike down key parts of the
affordable care act he frequently called
for overturning roe v wade
he opposed marriage equality he voted to
gut the protections and the voting
rights
in the shelby case he voted to gut our
campaign finance laws and citizen united
case
he made it harder for workers who were
discriminated against by their employers
to seek justice in court and further
stack the deck in favor of wealthy
business owners
and corporations over working class
individuals by nominating judge barrett
president trump is attempting to bring
justice scalia's judicial philosophy
back
to the mainstream and our nation's
highest court
placing judge barrett on the supreme
court puts at risk
so many of the rights and protections
americans have fought for and gained
so let's look how the law could change
if judge barrett is confirmed that's the
second reason to oppose this nomination
her judicial philosophy in addition to
the flawed
process you cannot always predict how a
supreme court justice will act
after her confirmation but judge barrett
has given us
clear views on her philosophy so many of
the american rights
are on the line but let me start with
talking about
the affordable care act judge barrett
has made her views quite clear about the
affordable care act
in 2017 law review article she concluded
that the aca
is unconstitutional she wrote chief
justice roberts pushed the affordable
care act beyond its plausible meaning
to save the statute judge barrett argued
that the chief justice roberts approach
to
nfib versus sebelius which was joined by
justice ginsburg
expressed a commitment to judicial
restraint
by creatively interpreting ostensibly
clear statutory language
and that its approach is at odds with
the statutory textualism
to which most originalists subscribe
in another uh supreme court case king
versus burwell the supreme court in the
6-3 decision
joined by justice ginsburg affirmed
health insurance tax credits
for millions of families nearly nine
million americans depend on these tax
credits for coverage
barrett criticized the decision stating
i think the dissent has the better
of the legal arguments and elsewhere she
wrote
justice scalia's criticizing the
majority's construction
of the affordable care act and nfib
versus sibelius and king versus burwell
protested that the statute known as
obamacare should be renamed scotus care
in honor of the court's willingness to
rewrite the statute
in order to keep it afloat by this
measure it is illegitimate for the court
to distort either the constitution or a
statute
to achieve what it deems a preferable
result
it's clear to me and it should be clear
to all of us that judge barrett
has a clear bias against the affordable
care act
president trump has repeatedly stated
that he would appoint judges who would
overturn
the aca and has consistently done so in
terms of his appellate
and trial court nominations judge
barrett
appears to meet president trump's litmus
test
i mentioned these cases to underscore
the importance of the supreme court
justice in the lives of all americans
so much is at stake in the filling of
justice ginsburg's vacancy
your health care is literally on the
line
the affordable care act that president
trump has tried to repeal and the
republicans tried to appeal in this body
but have failed they're now going to
take it to the supreme court
a hearing is scheduled this november
10th in the case of california versus
texas
just one week after the general election
this is a real risk for tens of millions
of americans who depend on the law for
their
health care coverage and other benefits
20 million americans could lose their
health care
and people with pre-existing conditions
could lose those protections
that's 133 million americans during the
corona
pandemic that's what is at stake
we are talking about pregnancy cancer
diabetes high blood pressure behavioral
health disorders high cholesterol asthma
chronic lung disease heart disease and
numerous
others that have been held to be
pre-existing conditions before the
protection in the affordable care act
and you can now add covet to those
preconditioned
for eight million americans and counting
that protection is in the affordable act
this is on the line before the supreme
court this november
if the affordable care act has struck
down insurers could bring back annual
and lifetime limits on coverage
adults coverage uh by medicare expansion
we lose vital health services
young people will be kicked off with
their parents insurance and insurers
could sell
skimpy plans that don't even cover
essential health benefits like
prescription drugs or
emergency room visits mental health and
substance use and maternity
care the affordable care act increased
access to care for
millions who were previously uninsured
or underinsured
through medicaid expansion 13 million
low-income americans
now have dependable comprehensive health
coverage
in maryland alone over 1.3 million
low-income
individuals depend on medicaid including
510
12 000 low-income children 107 thousand
seniors 152 000 individuals with
disability
that is just in maryland we must protect
the medicaid expansion population
and other uninsured and underinsured
populations from the trump
administration's effort
to eliminate their access to affordable
care
it is at risk i have similar concerns
about women's health care issues
judge barrett has already gone on record
in opposition to reproductive rights and
freedom so it's clear to me that she
would try to roll back the clock
on those rights as a supreme court
justice
in a 2013 speech she entitled roe at 40.
judge barrett explained that republicans
are heavily invested
in getting judges who will overturn roe
she wrote that the framework of roe has
essentially permitted abortion on demand
and roe recognizes no
state interest in the life of the fetus
in a 23
2003 article judge barrett suggested
that roe v
wade was an erroneous decision
recall that president trump has already
said he would only nominate justices who
would
automatically overturn roe v wade judge
barrett appears
to have met this litmus test as well
indeed judge barrett may hold an even
more extreme
record when it comes to reproductive
rights uh
than than than i've already stated she
refused to say
at her confirmation hearing whether
griswold versus connecticut was rightly
decided
in which the court held that the
constitution guarantees a right
to marital privacy and that a law
criminalizing the use of contraception
violated that right now note that just
justices roberts alito kagan and
kavanaugh
all discussed the griswold case at their
confirmation hearing
yet judge barrett said that the
griswold's correctness
quote is something i cannot opine on
judge barrett's views on immigration
also raises concerns
our most vulnerable individuals are at
risk as well as
with the naming of a new justice to the
supreme court
let me talk about one specific group on
june 18th
of this year in a 5-4 decision written
by chief justice roberts and joined by
justice ginsburg
the supreme court held that the
department of homeland security violated
law when it rescinded
the deferred action for childhood
arrival daca program
there are approximately 643 000 daca
recipients these are our dreamers
in the united states and approximately
29
000 are health care workers essential
workers who are serving us during covet
19 pandemic
who have saved lives and ease suffering
but for
the 5'4 decision those individuals lives
could have been totally
and they could have been ordered to
leave our country these are individuals
who know
no other home but the united states of
america there are our neighbors and
friends
the next justice could very well
determine the fate
of the dreamers unfortunately judge
barrett already has demonstrated a
judicial track record
which is hostile to immigration in cook
county versus wolf judge barrett
authored the dissenting opinion
from a ruling that struck down the trump
um
trump administration's cruel public
charge rule
the rule basically penalize immigrants
for exercising their legal rights
to use benefits that congress has made
available
and in the case of ifalli versus pompeo
judge barrett wrote the majority opinion
and held that the u.s consular officials
have virtually
unchecked authority to deny visa
applications
to those seeking entrance to the united
states
it was pointed out in the minority
opinion that the
uh the the majority has created
a constant dangerous abdication of
judicial responsibility that would lead
immigration
officials to deny visas on the basis
of implementable bias
so let me turn to the rights of the
lgbtq community
in the oprah fell versus hodges case
joined by justice ginsburg
the supreme court held that the
constitution guarantees same-sex couples
the right to marry in a 5-4 decision
unfortunately judge barrett has
demonstrated hostility to marriage
equality
and the lgbtq rights more generally
in speeches judge barrett seems to be
critical of the supreme court's
decisions in uberfield
indicating she was worried about the who
decides question
when it comes to the courts or
legislatures deciding who can marry
and start a new family but fundamental
rights under constitution should not be
up for debate every american should have
the same rights benefits and obligations
of marriage regardless of their gender
or who they love notably judge barrett
referred to sexual orientation and
sexual preference and her testimony
implying that sexual orientation is a
choice instead of an immutable
characteristic
as justice kennedy concluded in oberfeld
no union is more profound than marriage
for it embodies the highest ideals of
love fidelity devotion sacrifice of
family
informing of a marital uni union two
people become something greater than
once they were
as some of the petitioners in this case
demonstrate marriage embodies a love
that may endure even past death
it would be misunderstood these men and
women to say
they disrespect the idea of marriage
their plea
is that they do respect it respect is so
deeply that they seek to fulfill its
its obligations themselves their hope is
not to be condemned to life
of loneliness excluded from one of
civilization's oldest institutions
they ask for equal dignity in the eyes
of the law
the constitution grants them that right
i hope we agree with justice ginsburg
but i'm afraid
that's a view that is not shared by
judge bennett
judge bennett was critical as well as
the extension of civil rights laws to
protect transgender people saying
an event that it does seem to strain the
text of a statue to say the title ix
demands it however the supreme court
held otherwise in boxted versus clayton
county
where justice gorsuch joined by justice
ginsburg held for the court in a 6-3
decision
that prohibition of employment
discrimination on the basis of sex
should read to include gender identity
and sexual
orientation judge barrett
has issued several disturbing findings
that indicate a cramped
and narrow view of civil rights laws
designated to protect american workers
from discrimination based on race or age
in eeoc
versus autozone judge barrett voted
against rehearing
a panel decision that ruled against an
african-american employee
whose company involuntarily transferred
him to another store
based on race the eoc had charged that
autozone
had an unlawful practice of segregating
employees by race when it assigned
african-american employees to stores in
african-american neighborhoods
and latino employees to latino
neighborhoods
the dissent argued that the court upheld
a separate but equal arrangement
that is contrary to the supreme court's
decision the brown v
board of education when the court
interpreted the equal protection clause
of the 14th amendment
to find that separate facilities can't
be equal
the ascent wrote the case presents a
straightforward question
under title seven of the civil rights
act
of 1964. does the business policy of
segregating employees
and intentionally assigning members of
different races to different stores tend
to deprive an individual of employment
opportunities on the basis of race
the panel answered this question no
no not necessarily i cannot agree
with that conclusion once again judge
barrett was on the side of denying
protection
against racial discrimination in climber
versus
care fusion corporation judge brower
cited with the majority that age
discrimination and employment act
only protects current employees from
discrimination due to disparate impact
and not outside job applicants
a very narrow view and then there's
judge barrett's views on gun safety that
i find
deeply concerning judge barrett's record
strongly suggests that she would strike
down common sense gun safety laws
even as congress and the states continue
to try to combat
gun violence which kills nearly 40 000
americans
every year according to the center for
american progress from
2008 to 2017 over 6 200 people were
killed with guns in maryland
and from 2014 through 2018 there were 42
mass shootings in maryland killing
a total of 45 people and injuring 156
that's just in one state
the next supreme court justice could
hold the decisive vote
should congress or the states adopt
common-sense gun safety laws to curb
gun violence such as requiring universal
background checks
banning assault weapons or banning high
capacity
magazine clips in cantor v bar
the seventh circuit held that a law
barring felons from possessing a firearm
did not violate the second amendment the
supreme court
previously held in the district court
versus heller that the second amendment
conveyed an individual right to bear
arms
separate from the right of the militia
to do so
even justice scalia judge barrett's
mentor
and president trump's role model for an
ideal justice
wrote in his majority opinion for the
court
in heller that nothing in our opinion
should be taken to cast out on the
long-standing
prohibition on the possession of
firearms by felons
yet judge barrett's dissent in cantor
and concluded that the bar on gun
possession should not
should only apply to violent felons she
argued that the majority was treating
the second amendment like a second class
right
she went on to note that the government
could deny
non-violent felons the right to vote
but not the right to bear arms because
history does show that felons can be
disqualified from exercising certain
rights
like the right to vote and serve on
juries because these rights
belong only to virtuous citizens
so ultimately judge barrett's bizarrely
seems to treat
voting rights as a second class right
compared to gun ownership that's pretty
extreme
of all